Let's look at the
angular momentum
of two particles, one sitting
here and one over there.
And they are
circling each other.
And we want to
determine the angular
momentum of a point on the
ground right here underneath.
That's the whole point, s.
And here is the center.
So the circle has radius, R.
And here we have a height, h.
and let's have the particles
go counterclockwise.
Because then we can define
our k hat vector to go up.
And if these particles
are going this way,
then omega is also going to be
going in the k hat direction--
in the positive k hat direction.
So we know that L
equals r cross p.
So we need to determine where
is r and what's going on with p.
So our r vector goes here from
point s to our first particle,
rs1.
And here is number two.
And we have rs2
sitting over here.
And p, the momentum of
the particles-- well,
if these guys going in the
counterclockwise direction,
then the momentum
of particle one
is going to go into
the board following
the direction of the motion.
And here p2 is going to
come out of the board.
If we consider
this equation here,
we can already
graphically determine
what the answer is
actually going to be.
And so we do r cross p.
So r cross p, which
means L. Ls1 is going
to point in this direction.
Ls1.
And alternatively,
Ls2 is going to go
this direction, which means if
we add these two components--
and we do want the total
angular momentum of the system
of both particles.
So we have to add them.
We'll get here our
L of the system.
So in order to
calculate that, we
need to calculate first
the Ls1 and then the Ls2.
And then we need to add them.
The crucial point
here is to be careful
with the coordinate system.
For the first particle,
k is going up.
And r is going outwards.
And theta hat is
going into the board.
Then we can write up
Ls1 equals rs1 cross p1.
And we can express this
vector here with h and with r.
So we have R in
the r hat direction
plus h in the k hat
direction cross p.
And p is the mass of the
particle times the angular
velocity, the component.
That is R omega z.
And that goes in
the theta direction.
So we need to solve
this cross product here.
And we're going to have
mR squared omega z.
And then we have r
hat cross theta hat.
That's k hat plus hmR omega z.
And then we have k
hat cross theta hat.
That's anti-cyclic.
And we get an r hat.
And this is, by the way, an r1.
And this is another r1.
And we get a minus
because it's anti-cyclic.
So we're going to turn
this here into a minus.
And that is the angular
momentum for our first particle.
Now we're going to do
the same in an analogous
way for particle number two.
But again, we need to look
at the coordinate system.
That's very crucial here.
So k hat still goes up.
r hat now goes into
the other direction.
And accordingly, theta hat
comes out of the board.
And then we can just write down
our Ls2 here as the same thing,
mR squared omega z k hat.
And here we have minus
hmR omega z r2 hat.
And we know from our setup here
that r1 equals minus r2 hat.
r1 hat equals
minus r2 hat, which
means when we now
put it all together,
we want L equals Ls1 plus Ls2.
We can tally this up.
And from this, we will see
that the r hat term actually
falls out.
And we are left with 2
times the first term.
So we have 2mR
squared omega z k hat.
And that's exactly
what we wanted.
We wanted an L pointing
in the k hat direction.
That's exactly this here.
And what you can also
see is that the 2m here
is the mass, the total
mass of the system, namely
two particles.
We could add another--
we could do the
same exercise again
for four points because
we'll add two here.
Then we would get 4m here.
So this is the
mass of the system.
And if we were to add many, many
more points all along the rim
here, we get to a
solid ring, which
means that either we know
the total mass of the ring
that we could stick in here.
Or we can integrate
along the rim
and then get to the
total mass here.
And we'll always get to
the same kind of form.